happy monday everybody here we are
november 15th we're already halfway
through november the the these last two
months of the year just fly don't they
beautiful skies out there lots of blue
sky just giving you a heads up if we can
keep the skies clear enough for the peak
of the leonids meteor shower this week
that's the night of november 17th going
into the morning of the thursday morning
overnight so that night it looks like we
may
get rid of a lot of the clouds from
wednesday into thursday more clouds
clouds coming in tonight tomorrow and
then again on friday but this may be
just the perfect window to see these
we will have a building fuller waxing
moon so the moonlight is going to
interfere a little bit but 10 to 15
shooting stars per hour so if you can
get away from the bright city lights you
may be able to see some of those
shooting stars 50s around the valley
this morning a couple of spots are
cooler red rocket 45 nellis at 47 seven
hills in the 40s as well there's been a
little breeze up at kyle canyon keeping
the temperatures milder up there this
morning we've got 40s in mesquite low
40s in indian springs freezing in
caliani below freezing in ely 55 in
laughlin and parum you're right at 50
degrees sandy valley at 51. so we're
going to cool those numbers down and
that's thanks to this system does have a
cold front with it that will push
through the west
tomorrow and ahead of it it will push
through a lot of high clouds we're
already starting to see some of those
high clouds coming in so we'll call it
mostly sunny but mixing up with a few
high clouds today and super mild like
the weekend up near 80 degrees a normal
high for mid-november is 67 and check
out these numbers to start the week more
clouds around tomorrow breezes
especially along the colorado river for
wednesday but you see the temps slide
mid 70s tomorrow low 70s to finish the
week might even have a day or two around
around 69 so slightly above normal
mornings in the 40s no rain but there
will be clouds from time to time